this has a first chink-in-the-arm feel
to it
a little
better not yet
oh so dear how was your day
well my day was illuminating
come sit with me
what's that
um
the proper term for it would be a
juxtaposition
i don't know what that means but
i know baby
look at that
looks like an o-ring
oh yeah
halfway right
i didn't think you were a diamonds and
gold kind of girl
you know what i mean
yeah
i don't need presents beth
just you
well that's what it means
it means that you
that you have me that i'm yours
it means come live your life with me
the only thing i ask is that you outlive
me so i never have to live another day
without you
i can try and do that
okay
it's settled
we'll get married
married
yeah baby i'm asking you to marry me
will you do that
i mean i
i would have to ask your father now
it's handled
he spares you the indignity
so what'd he say
i mean i
was like sometimes actually
yeah yes
beth i can't go to the courthouse
there's no record i even exist on this
planet
yeah well
marriage license that's just a contract
right it's just
business
we ain't going into business together
so marriage to me is
can you take me one of those mountains
in front of my family
my friends
i don't have any friends but should i
make one
you would stand in front of them
and you would tell them that there is no
more you and i
there's only us
i can do that
[Music]
you